- Everybody has sex.
- Not me.
(laughing)
(upbeat instrumental music)
- When you come to a sex shop--
- Don't deep-throat a dildo.
- Spank each other.
- Not around us 'cause we
didn't give you consent
and we don't wanna see it.
- People should act like
an adult in an adult store.
- Save the shenanigans for your home.
- We love you, we love the
fact that you wanna buy
all this stuff and that
you're so excited to try it,
but try it at home.
- What about that guy
who used his wife's card
to buy his girlfriend something?
- My favorite story so far is a person
who came in and purchased lube,
which I was so excited for because it's
one of those things
that people gloss over.
However, he also asked to use the bathroom
and knocked on the door and heard noises
that I was not prepared to hear.
It's just really awkward after that,
so just don't masturbate
in public bathrooms please.
- We'll miss you.
- People used to go to the
bathroom and then we would
be missing, you know,
displays of butt plugs.
Like hiding toys in their
bodies and then leaving
and walking out of the store.
Like, A+ for effort, I guess,
but a F- on the fact
that it's a display toy.
I don't wanna shame anybody but everybody
in New York touches our toys.
You're gonna want a clean one
before you do that anyway,
and lubricant, I'm sure
they didn't do it with lube.
- Everybody is different,
everybody's body's different,
so it's good to go to stores
because you can get educated,
you can see and feel things.
It's different from looking online
because it could look like it's this small
and then in person it's, like, so big.
- Pro tip, testing the
vibrators on your nose
will be similar to the
nerve sensitivity of,
like, your other bits.
- Don't feel ashamed.
Nobody's gonna judge
you and even if there's
customers in there, they're in there too
so they're not gonna judge you
because they're in there too.
Just feel, like, calm and at ease.
Like, we're here for you,
what do you wanna buy?
- Folks come in and try
to purchase services
other than the education of sex toys.
Do not ask if we have the
toys, if we use the toys.
It'd be kind of silly if
we worked in a sex shop
and didn't have any toys
for many, many reasons.
You know, we all gotta benefit somehow.
- You know, ask questions respectfully.
Don't ask me what my favorite thing is
because I guarantee you we're
not on the same wavelength.
- We may know that you are
looking for a butt plug,
but I don't know your last
name so let's keep it there.
- We're here to sell you things,
help us out help you
find out what you want
because we just met you.
(upbeat instrumental music)